[Applaus]
so hab ich war vorher begeistern
das ist wie wenn zusammenbrechen es war
um sechs uhr morgens in deutschland seit
sehr sehr deprimierend der hat gewonnen
dass unser präsident 64 ja punkt trump
ist ungeeigneten diese rolle
ich konnte das nicht glauben kann hat
eine gar nicht damit gerechnet das sind
diese amt kommt das ist nicht leicht von
1 tag beim nächste hast du eine
millionen mitarbeiter kampert ganz
andere erwartungen ich weiß nicht welche
schule kann man diese job lernen
der ist ein fernseh figur
das ist schlimmer geworden als ich
eigentlich erwartet es ist habe ich
eigentlich dann befürchtet mit seinen
amtseinführungen januar letztes jahr und
das die erwartung war eigentlich schon
dass es schlimmere sachen passieren
würde das ist tatsächlich passiert ich
bin begeistert dass wir einen präsident
haben das pult america first americans
präsident aus
michael auch der der ist eine man das
sagt was er denkt ist ungewöhnlich
freien states stets man also was ich
wenn ein präsident er war das aber das
kommt ist oder ob das der nächste oder
der frühjahr ist einfach intelligenz 1 1
zeigen dass mainka römische verhältnisse
eigentlich zurecht kommt nicht einfach
nach gefühl und spontan reagieren meint
ihr ist das eher wenig geld bietet
okay dass er ein bisschen es mal
überlegt was elf sagte konsequenzen
dadurch hat beispiele kommt immer wieder
das unberechenbar ist und das spielt
eine rolle dass leute den kabinett eine
gewählt haben
aber seine erfahrung das heißt weniger
erfahren zu regieren momentan der
wirtschaft in die märkte pumpt der
aktienmarkt ist auf höchste rekord wo
eigentlich die dekra gesagt das wird ein
großes flop in der history deshalb
nichts passiert ja das ist lächerlich
also wie etwa trump ein tatsächlich sich
anzieht was er für eine frisur hat
selber scheinbar gefärbt sein gesicht
farbe das ist comic figur kann man sagen
aber es ist nichts mehr zu lachen
jeder hat seine art aber wie kann ich
niemandem vom sein hartes urteil ist
aktion ist was er gemacht hat seinen
handabdruck finde ich bisschen harmlos
[Musik]
das ist eine seiner art wie man sich
merken es handel schützt nicht so
wichtig
ein blick auf amerika hat sich schon
verändert als auch wenn deutschland aus
dem ausland aus sieht man das sowieso
anderes meinen blick auf merkels ist ist
komplette pause ich sehe eigentlich
schon zeit trump im amt ist bzw schon
seit der wahlkampf das amberger märkisch
gespaltet ist beziehungsweise in
deutschland einem erker das geht weil
das der adolf würth verkaufte in
innovation unter hamburgs werden gerade
neue hamburger laden aufgemacht
feingeist bahn in frankfurt vor
also ich finde es toll tourismus dieser
okay leute waren immer noch fünf im
konsulat verwiesen und beziehungen zur
portal weise ist es so extrem dass diese
verdienen werde eigentlich eine reise
absagen wird ein erster test nicht nach
usa gehen verstehe ich bemerke ist nicht
schwanger
das ist das was ist of america america
wir sollten nie vergessen dass amerika
die die die beziehung zwischen uns ist
so stark
eine trommel für seinen vier jahren kann
das nicht brechen ich würde eigentlich
nie so richtig und geschimpft beschimpft
oder angespuckt oder so was war ich dann
endlich mehr erkranken zeitraum da ist
mein leben schwerer dadurch natürlich da
muss sie eigentlich sagen das sind in
deutschland ist obama fast übertrieben
geliebt und ist immer noch geliebt also
das ist das spielt eine große rolle
natürlich das ist ein krasser
unterschied jetzt natürlich sehen die
deutschen das anders
[Musik]